promised help is on the way and today
help has arrived nine most terrifying
words in the English language are I'm
from the government and I'm here to help
all right people it's December 7th 2022
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
we are back live as usual I apologize
for no live shows uh the last two days I
was away doing some family stuff
actually had my nephews Bar Mitzvah in
New York over the weekend they did not
play any Kanye during the bar mitzvah a
good time was had by all and then on
Monday I was in Washington DC I was
given a talk to the newly elected
Congressional Republicans about
messaging and social media and a bunch
more hint I said be more like Florida
that was the main message and before we
get to anything today you may note that
my voice is a little more hoarse or
something a little more twangy twingy
little little bit of a frog in there it
turns out that yesterday when I returned
back to the free state of Florida with
the Dewey sweet humid air that is here
after being in New York and DC with the
crackling cold dry air
my throat was a little itchy scratchy
whatever the voice was a little off
which I thought was just uh because I
was having a blast with the family and
yelling and dancing all night and
sweating up the storm blah blah blah
anyway I got home because I wasn't a
hundred percent and we have two babies
here David said why don't you take a
covid test I took the covid test it came
back positive pretty quickly so I do
have covid that's right we're doing a
covid show uh I said to my guys last
night I said guys just FYI I've got
kovid I'm not pressuring anyone to come
into work is what it is you know I think
at this point it's just like a little
cold or a flu but you know I want to be
respectful of my guys I don't force them
to get vaccinated and I don't force them
to be in a room with me if I have covid
and to quote them directly I wrote it
down what you both said when I said uh
you know if you want to come into work
Connor you said I laugh in the face of
death and Phoenix you said screw you old
man which I thought was very uh that's
how much these people love coming to
work so we are in here Clyde is in here
with us today and mostly I'm just going
to be spending it's a beautiful day in
Florida it's about 75 and Sunny I'm
going to be hanging out in the backyard
I'll hit the gym for a little bit maybe
do some swimming I'll shoot some hoops
I'm going to survive oh and more
important than anything else I you don't
have to worry about me you really don't
have to worry about me folks I'm unfaxed
I'm unboxed I'm unboosted I am I'm pure
blood I'm good to go I'm gonna be okay
I'll drink some water there's a little
lemon in the tea it's going to be all
right everything's fine anyway we got a
big show for you I'm glad to be back in
studio mostly what we're going to catch
up on a couple things that happened over
the last few days the big thing of
course was I believe it was on Friday
night
these Twitter files dropped and Elon
Elon now has access to all of the
nonsense and that's why the machine is
crashing down on him right that's why
every day New York Times and Washington
Post and CNN and all The Usual Suspects
that's why they're writing hit pieces on
Elon Musk every day now that's why the
government is looking into his
businesses because he now has all the
files did the government coordinate to
get rid of the hunter Biden laptop story
well we've got some evidence now did the
government coordinate to eliminate
certain people who were saying things
out of the narrative or against the
narrative when it came to covid well
we've got some evidence now and we're
going to get more and more evidence and
you're going to watch the machine right
we've seen this many times how does the
cancel machine swarm on people
just remember a couple months ago Joe
Rogan remember that week when he was
racist because he said the n-word years
ago and there was everybody talking
about how he had to get booted from
Spotify that's the exact same thing the
machine is doing on Elon now except it's
a little trickier to stop the world's
richest man who has been preparing for
this for quite some time anyway I'm
going to connect that to a million other
things
I have to say despite having this
debilitating disease I'm feeling very
sharp today guys are you both feeling
you're feeling sharp like we can do a
good show today all right very exciting
and then of course we're going to end
with some some ways out of the madness
because I really do believe that there
are ways out before we get to any of
that let me talk to you guys about Tommy
John you know fall is chaos in your
pants you're overheating one second and
freezing the next to be ready for
anything you need underwear that can
handle everything it's time for Tommy
John underwear in Tommy John underwear
you're that much more comfortable so you
can do everything better Tommy John's
breathable lightweight fabric has four
times the stretch of competing Brands
they come with a no wedgie guarantee
thanks to a non-rolling waistband and
legs that never ride up plus they
feature a horizontal Quick Draw fly
hammock pouch support stops the awkward
swing and slap giving everyone something
to be grateful for with over 18 million
pairs sold people love Tommy John
underwear that's why why Tommy John
doesn't have customers they have
Fanatics plus everything's backed by
Tommy John's best pair you'll ever wear
or its free guarantee go to
tommyjohn.com Reuben right now for 20
off your first order 20 off at Tommy Don
tommyjohn.com reuben tommyjohn.com
reuben Seaside for details and now back
to me all right so let's just dive right
into it I think I'm going to be catching
you guys up on a little bit that I
missed over the over the two days uh but
you know more info is dropping on this
on this Twitter leak this Twitter files
drop every second uh
so let's just get caught up here's a
tweet from Elon Musk himself what really
happened with the hunter Biden story
suppression by Twitter will be published
on Twitter at 5 00 PM Eastern that was
on December 2nd so that was on Friday
and now we've got some info from the
daily wire Twitter CEO Elon Musk
released internal company Communications
through journalist Matt taibi on Friday
about the company's censorship of the
New York post's Hunter Biden laptop
story during the 2020 presidential
election and about how the platform
removed content at the behest of the
Democrat Party contained in the batch of
files which taibi released in a lengthy
Twitter thread was an email from former
Twitter Deputy general counsel Jim Baker
about how the company should handle the
hunter Biden laptop story I support the
conclusion that we need more facts to
assess whether the materials were hacked
baker said in the email at this stage
however it is reasonable for us to
assume that they may have been and that
caution is warranted there are some
facts that indicate that the materials
may have been hacked while there are
others indicating that the computer was
either abandoned and or the owner
consented to allow the repair shop to
access it for at least some purposes we
simply need more information taibi
failed to mention in his initial release
that Baker and get this I mean this is
wild guys was the former FBI general
counsel involved in russia-related
investigations into former president
Donald Trump and then this guy ends up
working at Twitter the next installment
of the Twitter files was supposed to
happen over the weekend but became
delayed for a reason that was Known
Unknown at the time taibi now says that
the reason for the delay was that it was
discovered that Baker was responsible
for betting the files that were released
to him and journalist Barry Weiss musk
immediately fired Baker upon learning
the news in light of concerns about
Baker's possible role in suppression of
the information important to the public
dialogue he was exited from Twitter
today musk tweeted Baker is a
controversial figure he has been
something of a zelig of FBI
controversies dating back to 2016 from
the Steele dossier
to the alpha server mess he resigned in
2018 after an investigation into leaks
to the Press taibi concluded okay so do
you guys get let's put aside the content
of the leaks for a moment right because
I think most of us whether Elon had
released this stuff or not most of us at
this point if you are a somewhat
thinking person if you've got a couple
neurons firing in your brain and you're
not just a generic NPC we've all known
that there was some level of the of
coordination between the government and
big Tech when it came to the hunter
Biden laptop story and certainly and I
think we're going to find out more about
this related to covid what really is the
crazy part of this is this Jim Baker
piece you have this guy who worked at
the FBI who stepped down was involved in
the steel dossier somehow ends up at
Twitter and he's the guy betting the
releases as elon's putting it out then
as Elon found out about that he
immediately fires him like this if this
was a a mystery movie you'd almost think
it was too obvious course the FBI guy
ends up working at Twitter like it's
just it's just too obvious it's wild
anyway Glenn Greenwald Glenn Greenwald
who is a lefty I know he goes on Tucker
a lot now people think he's a crazy
right winger but he's a lefty he went on
Tucker to discuss uh what's going on
with with this level of strange
coordination that seems to be happening
between big government and big Tech
Baker from the FBI wind up the general
counsel of Twitter a lot of lawyers in
this country a lot of capable lawyers
but you hire the FBI lawyer at the
center of russiagate I mean that seems
like a means of control by a government
agency over a social media company to me
the tentacles of the U.S Security State
are in almost every single institution
of authority and Power in this country I
still find it mind-boggling how it used
to be controversial and the CIA would
have programs to clandestinely influence
news outlets
okay so they obviously continued on that
but you I just wanted to play that small
snippet because this is really
incredible stuff an FBI lawyer was
working at Twitter do you really
understand that and then was vetting the
releases as they came out God bless Elon
Musk the second he found out about it he
fires the guy but this is crazy crazy
stuff and what I really think look the
hunter Biden laptop stuff I don't care
about Hunter Biden smoking crack on a
webcam or banging hookers or whatever
snorting cocaine off the floor when
looking for cheese or whatever he said
he was doing I don't care about that
stuff that much like that's people have
addictions people have people do all
sorts of things like I'm libertarian
mostly when it comes to drugs although I
don't think he should be smoking crack
however his business dealings emails to
his father about money going to the big
man and how did he get this crazy job at
barisma a guy who was a crackhead who
had no experience in the energy sector
like these are things that are important
the fact that Jim Baker at Twitter was
basically implying like oh we don't know
if this was hacked or not when there was
no evidence that it was hacked right
from beat one everybody was saying that
Hunter dropped the laptop off at the
repair shop that's what the repair shop
owner said that's what Rudy Giuliani who
eventually got the laptop said and then
of course the FBI starts looking into
Rudy so there's something really really
nuts here and what I think this really
leads to beyond the corruption related
to barisma and Ukraine and not to say
that's not important because we're in
this war not war with Ukraine and it
feels like these things are somewhat
connected and there's some weird money
laundering thing going on there okay
fine to me the the much bigger fish in
this thing is what did the government do
related to covid when there were those
of us who were saying maybe this was a
lab leak or there were those of us that
that we're saying that vaccine mandates
were coming or that vaccines don't work
as promised or maybe that we should have
more clinical trials or maybe that you
shouldn't kick kids out of school and
lock people down and there's going to be
second order effects and all of that
stuff if the government was stepping on
our Free Speech related to that well
then there's something really
um it's deeply important and it's deeply
important because if we don't figure out
what happened
if we don't realize that boy there were
some people that were right about some
things and they were treated really
horribly and people who were horrible
about things and wrong about things were
treated really well we'll never get to
reconcile what happened and maybe maybe
that's what the system wants right it
wants this endless nonsensical
time-release truth situation where
everyone will eventually get tired of
saying the truth because you won't get
any credit for it right you will be
treated like a freak for it I can give
you a personal example of that you may
remember me Dave Rubin your humble covet
having YouTube host back in July of 2021
uh here is what I tweeted uh that you
can look down below is well here's my
tweet from yesterday because I
referenced it I said now that we have
some insight into the hunter laptop
coordination just imagine what Elon Musk
is sitting on related to covid I was
suspended in July of 2021 for saying
vaccines don't work and mandates were
coming was this coordinated by someone
in the government so the tweet that I
was suspended on Twitter for in July of
2021 and it's hard to remember that year
and a half ago how different things were
because this was before Federal vaccine
mandates and before they were forcing
boosters and everything else I said they
want a federal vaccine mandate for
vaccines which are clearly not working
as promised just weeks ago people are
getting and transmitting covid despite
facts plus now they're prepping us for
booster shots the same society would
take a pause we do not live in a sane
Society I was suspended for that
um ultimately I was able because I have
locals thank God I was able to
communicate with my audience they were
then able to amplify the message and
then Twitter did actually reverse my
suspension they said it was an accident
but the question is when it comes to
that tweet or or literally thousands and
thousands maybe hundreds of thousands
and millions of others did someone at
the from the government from the
intelligence agencies whatever it might
be contact someone at Twitter and say
this information cannot get out there
now you must delete it and if they did
and I think there's a high likelihood
they did then in this case my first
amendment rights
were violated now I've actually spoken
to a couple lawyers about this there's
not much you could do about that like if
the government infringes on your first
amendment rights like it's hard to put a
monetary value on that you might be able
to get an apology out of them that would
be something right the government
actually admitting what it did making
sure that the other the people that uh
were at Twitter are held to account for
their involvement in this that the
people in the government maybe they can
get fired like that's something I'm not
sitting here like I want a million
dollars from the US government because
of my tweet
but there is something to all this and
and the point is I was right that that's
what I'm trying to show you I'm not
trying to make this about me but there
were a lot of people that were right
about a lot of stuff stuff and we were
treated very poorly by by certainly by
the mainstream media and by Big Tuck big
Tech and everything else now I want to
show you how perverse when when the
truth is hidden what happens lies expand
everywhere and then that actually helps
people get elected two months after that
in September of 2021 you may remember
there was a recall in California for
Gavin Newsom and then there was election
about the recall now the recall did not
go the way I wanted obviously and Larry
Elder did not become governor of
California but I want to show you this
ad that was put up it was blasted
non-stop in the summer of 2021 and into
September right up to the recall this is
Gavin newsom's attack ad on Larry Elder
talking about vaccines and mandates and
a whole bunch more and you'll see at the
end just watch really close at the end
when you see the text it was funded by
Reed Hastings the CEO of Netflix just as
an interesting little uh tidbit to the
story all right take a look what's at
stake in the September 14th recall it's
a matter of life and death with Delta
surging Gavin Newsom is protecting
California requiring vaccination for
health workers and School Employees the
top Republican candidate he peddled
deadly conspiracy theories and would
eliminate vaccine mandates on day one
threatening school closures and our
recovery stop the spread return your
Ballot or vote in person by September
14th protect California by voting no on
the Republican recall
do you see what I'm trying to show you
there so they call Larry Elder well he's
a dead he's spreading deadly conspiracy
theories because he doesn't want vaccine
mandates or mass mandates now California
doesn't have them right now although I'm
being told just in the last day or so
that La is thinking about bringing back
uh mask mandates and good luck with that
you want the freaking masks on again
good good you people have them but I'm
done with you guys okay fine that's what
you want you voted for it have at it but
the point is that two months after
someone like me tells the truth mandates
are coming boosters are coming vaccines
not working the reason I wrote the line
specifically vaccines are not working as
promised was because it was only a month
or so after Joe Biden very publicly said
if you get the vaccine you will not get
nor transmit covid so the point is there
are people who tell the truth you get
censored for it perhaps even by the
government we now know that and then
people who lie and take your rights away
and demand you get injected or demand
you get fired from your job if you don't
follow what they want those are the one
ones who get re-elected and then how do
they get reelected they get reelected
because people like Reed Hastings the
CEO of Netflix which most of you have
and pay money for pour tons of money
into getting an evil lizard person like
Gavin Newsom recalled
you see how I feel about this whole
thing
this is just the beginning people we've
got a big show for you let's talk about
moink box real quick uh you know that 60
of U.S pork production comes from one
company owned by the Chinese and their
Hogs are given something called
ractopamine which is banned in 160
countries including China yet you find
it in your grocery aisle every day
there's a better way I'd like to tell
you guys about moink that's moo plus
oink moink delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pasture
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught Alaskan salmon straight to your
door Mike Farmers Farm like our
grandparents did and as a result moink
meat tastes like it should because the
Family Farm Does It Better the moink
difference is a difference you can taste
and you can feel good knowing that
you're helping Family Farms stay
financially independent as well you
choose the meat delivered in every box
like rib eyes the chicken breasts to
pork chops and salmon fillets and much
more plus you can cancel any time my
favorite is their filet mignon Shark
Tank host Kevin O'Leary called moink's
bacon the best of bacon he's ever had
and ring doorbell founder Jamie simenovo
get the chance to invest in moink plus
they guarantee you'll say oink oink I'm
just so happy I got mocked keep American
farming going by signing up at
boinkbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get free filet
mignon in every order for a year that's
one of the best filet mignon you'll ever
taste but for a limited time that's
moinkbox.com
rubenmoybach.com Ruben and now back to
me all right
uh so how is the media reacting how is
the corporate press which was all about
people getting fired and all about
people getting censored and all about
people complying and not all about
people protesting and not all about
people exercising their free speech how
are they feeling about this this leak
right now how are they feeling about the
fact that we know that an FBI lawyer was
censoring documents that Elon Musk was
trying to release to the people he's
going around mainstream media that's
what this is really about what the Side
Story to all of this is not just the
information that we're learning about
the coordination the Side Story is that
Elon did not release the Twitter files
to CNN or to the New York Times or to
Washington Post or even the Wall Street
Journal he released it to Matt taibi who
is an independent journalist he released
it to Barry Weiss who is an independent
journalist by the way they both happen
to be left leaning taibi I I think now
he's kind of coming around to this side
let's say but he was a huge huge huge
Progressive Lefty five six years ago and
Barry you guys know I have certain
frustrations with her but she's still
basically a lefty Democrat like I would
argue very muddled and confused about
all the issues it's not like he brought
the information to Crazy freaking Ben
Shapiro and Glenn Beck right he gave it
to Lefty's but the point is it doesn't
matter who he gives it to they're going
to try to take him out because he didn't
give it to them here's CNN's Christine
Romans saying that now this stuff that's
not a big deal
look somewhere else now what some wants
you to think is that this was censorship
by big Tech and that's why the president
is saying you should throw out the
Constitution because big Tech is in
cahoots with American democracy that's
what the president thinks but what it
sort of shows is a real struggle at an
important platform for how to deal with
something so outrageous so explosive and
and what to actually do with it what
pointer said which is a immediate
Watchdog group they said um file this
one under file the Twitter files under M
for Ma and the Washington Post said
There Are No No Smoking Gun here God so
this lady on CNN basically says this is
nothing and then she refers to a website
pointer which is a media Watchdog which
no doubt gets Lefty money like it's just
obvious and what are they saying ah it's
not much what's Washington Post saying
owned by another billionaire right what
are they saying ah nothing to look at do
you guys think it's nothing to look at
but man they can confuse you about
everything so the average person and we
just have to accept that you know these
people I don't want to get rid of them I
don't want to silence them I don't want
to take away their voting rights or kick
them out of the country but we have to
ex we have to accept and I think the
last election is proof of it we have to
accept that a certain amount of people
just by the state line they just are
non-playable characters that's the NPC
meme they just if they hear something
that's how it is mainstream set it so
that's how it is sure six months later
two years later you know 60 Minutes will
acknowledge that the hunter Biden laptop
is real after uh they told Donald Trump
to his face that it's not real and they
can't cover it but that's all right and
that's why I keep saying the truth is a
Time release pill these days that's what
we're finding out but what the
mainstream media does is they make some
people look like Heroes when they
shouldn't but if it fits the narrative
they do they take bad people or they
take good people they make them look bad
they take bad people they make them look
good a great example of this if you want
an example of this remember Mike uh you
remember uh not Michael Steele uh wait
are we doing Michael Steele first no
we're doing the other one first right I
think you jumped ahead of me one here
oh we're gonna do Michael Steele okay
sorry
could that be covered brain did it just
did it just kick in at that moment uh a
good one of these is former RNC chairman
Michael Steele Michael Steele uh you
guys may remember he was former he was
the RNC chairman a couple years ago now
he's on MSNBC all the time just talking
about how bad Republicans are you'd
think he would still have some ability
to defend Free Speech as maybe someone
pretending to be a republican but no
it's not really working I guess with
musk is to prove that hey I'm the right
kind of Republican meaning I'm a trump
Republican I'm a uh you know election
denying Republican I don't know what
kind of Republican he is I mean probably
next year he'll be an independent or a
Democrat depending on how the wind blows
um but the but the reality of it is uh
putting those things back on the
platform uh juxtaposition with the
argument that he's all about free speech
um really undermines the central some of
the central tenets of
okay there's a lot there before I get to
the last line which was idiotic let me
just say that that show is the breast
Show on MSNBC
Connor liked that one you got it it was
the breast Show on MSNBC really
titillating you know
um
so somehow this man who once was sane
I've interviewed Michael Steele we used
to text every now and again uh he was he
was a decent guy actually I interviewed
him back in I think 2015. he was one of
the first guys explaining to me why
Trump was the real deal and the
frustration with the American people and
everything else we're going to leave
Clyde in here just let him be I've been
told I have to leave Clyde even though
he's making some noise I got to leave
him in here as to not upset the kids
right now
um but he clearly now he's an MSNBC
contributor and what he said there at
the end in essence was that free speech
meaning telling people what's really
going on releasing these files is
somehow anti-free speech it's absolutely
incredible but if you want incredible
here is a leftist activist who is on
MSNBC all the time her name is Brandy
zidrone I think she's called me a racist
once or twice uh and she's got an
interesting take on the Twitter files
when that came out we now know it was a
really helpful thing actually the
Twitter files today because we got to
see how content moderation works we got
to see how when a group of people with
differing political ideas and ideologies
and Views gets together in the spirit of
making a platform safe and healthy and
right before an election right when we
knew we had just learned of like the
hack and leaks and Wikileaks and all the
stuff that that did to hurt and to
affect the 2020 elect this 2016 election
in 2020 they were heightened right
people were trying to do the right thing
inside Twitter
all right everything she said there was
pure BS and nonsense first off when
people with differing views come
together her implication is that the
Twitter trust and safety team that they
had a diverse set of people there now
they may have had a diverse set when it
came to skin color and sexuality I
assume they had some girls with penises
and boys with vaginas that sort of thing
and that's very exciting when you're
going through content moderation you go
well what kind of genitals do you have I
don't know what kind of genitals do you
have
but they obviously didn't have
intellectual diversity on the board
deciding and then she goes on and on to
talk about the hacks and the leaks
related to WikiLeaks and we were finding
out all these what hacks and leaks what
hacks and leaks were there what hacks
the hunter Biden laptop was not hacked
it was handed by a crack addict to a
laptop repair guy right I mean if you
were a crack addict wouldn't you at
least go in and talk to the dorks over
at what are they the nerd dorks over at
Best Buy The Geek Squad the nerd dorks
that should be you know
you know but he went to like an
independent laptop guy who most likely
is gonna look at all your stuff at least
you give it to the nerd dorks and you
know there's other people around not
that they're up to no good and I'm
pretty sure it was discovered that the
government was even hiring The Geek
Squad to look at people's info but
that's the whole separate thing anyway
now here's the segment uh that I want to
show you before the media just gets
everything wrong and every now and again
you can go back and find Beautiful
Moments of the lies being exposed in
real time so here's where I want to give
credit where credit is due you remember
Matt Lauer Matt Lauer was beloved by
mainstream media for like 20 years
hosted the Today show I guess he ended
up harassing a couple women or something
he's gone now okay fine he was me too is
what it is uh but here he actually did a
pretty freaking decent job this is
amazing so this is video from 2016.
with Matt Lauer on The Today Show asking
then Twitter CEO Jack Dorsey if they
censor individuals this is this is just
spectacular and just watch this
knowing the backdrop of what we have
learned over the last couple days so let
me ask you point blank does Twitter
censor the content of its users does it
hide what it would consider inflammatory
comments whether they be social or
political absolutely not Twitter has
always been about controls people can
follow whoever they want and it's our
job to make sure they see the most the
most important things and the things
that don't matter to them so anybody can
say anything on Twitter the company does
not go in there and take certain things
out that can be dangerous well there's
certain there's certainly tweets that
promote violence which is against our
terms of service and people have
controls to block and people have
controls to mute but what about the
company who decides the difference
between criticism and hate these are
these are the individuals so you can
follow who you want and if it's
something you want to see you continue
to follow okay you really need to
understand I I think that video is going
to be used in a court of law against him
and and the company not only is he lying
there because he also like it's very
obvious that he's like he's basically
saying we don't do anything you could
decide what to do meaning you can block
you can mute you can unfollow somebody
but then he said at this and this is the
line if you're if you're a lawyer
interested in First Amendment and any of
this stuff Tech you this is the line our
job is they see the most important
things
well if your job is that they see the
most important things by default you're
ensuring that they won't see other
certain things because you're deciding
what's most important when most people
got on Twitter the idea was you are
going to follow people and see a purely
chronological feed with no manipulation
that's what you will see but their job
became to make sure you see the most
important things
well that means some things aren't going
to be as important so we are
manipulating and now we know that shadow
Banning exists that there were actual
tools at Twitter to make sure certain
people couldn't be seen or would be uh
suspended or whatever it might be and
that the government was coordinating all
over it so the reason I showed you that
is because I want to give Matt Lauer
credit Matt Lauer did a fine job there
but usually what the media does is
Elevate people who are bad and wrong
about everything so this is a this is
just a great video this is the uh you
may have heard over the weekend I'm not
even going to get into the bigger story
around around this but Michael avenatti
who was a media darling for a few years
he was just sentenced to 14 years in
prison for stealing millions of dollars
from his clients now this was the guy
who back in 2017 you remember he was on
TV every day and everybody was saying
how great he was because he was going to
take out Trump and he was going to be a
big star and maybe been president of the
United States well he's going to jail
now but here's video of 2017 when uh
well everyone loved him he's Donald
Trump's worst nightmare Michael already
joining us once again is Michael
avenatti that's bringing Michael
avenatti Michael avenatti Michael
avenatti Michael avenatti thank you very
much he's out there saving the country
says he may be the savior of the
Republic if you are something of a folk
hero now I owe Michael avenatti an
apology I've been saying enough for
writing Michael I've seen you everywhere
what do you have left to say I was wrong
brother you have a lot to say I am just
dying to hear what you think because
people all like you I'm the only person
right here Donald Trump fears more than
Robert Miller we think you guys are the
tip of this beer that's going to take
down Donald Trump Michael avenatti is a
beast yeah okay that's true and he's a
beast he's a beast I hand it to her and
I hand it to Michael avenatti and he has
a great bigger calling here that being a
lawyer is minimal compared to what he's
doing no one has talked tougher directly
to Donald Trump on TV than Michael
avenatti and Donald Trump is afraid to
mention his name name okay well he's
going to jail now and he never really
did anything good he didn't like Trump
so the media made him a hero so the
media even though Trump in my humble
opinion was doing a lot of good things
at least back in the day they treated
him like Hitler too and they treated
people who attacked him like they were
Jesus too but it's not just that and
it's important that you we go back in
these videos and see these things so you
remember so just that we remember
because if we don't remember how awful
they were and now really understand that
they coordinated the lies and they
laundered the lies through big Tech and
through big corporate press and all of
that stuff if we don't remember what
they did we will always be in this
Perpetual slide that is what I am trying
to stop that is why I do the show the
way that I do it because I don't want to
be part of that anymore I think most of
us don't want to be part of it but until
we can actually look at it like really
look at it
chew it taste it masticated that's a
word guys that's a word I'm not going to
be I know it sounded like another word
but I don't think we're going to be
demonetized masticate is a word until we
do that
we will never stop this thing and it's
still happening to this day so you know
you guys all know about this giant FTX
Scandal that this guy Sam bankman freed
was basically stealing billions of
dollars from Regular People celebrities
and and the like in his in his crypto
exchange that was a complete Ponzi
scheme nothingness it was all a lie but
he was treated absolutely wonderful
wonderfully by the mainstream media
here's video from CNBC just in this year
about how great this guy is and much
like avenatti turns out to be a criminal
Sam bakeman freed is really becoming the
industry's lifeline during a crisis
lately I'm fascinated endlessly
fascinated with Sam bankman Freed's role
in all of this you've been now described
as the JP Morgan if you will of the
crypto business a lot of people have
called you
um the savior of crypto the patron saint
of crypto the Michael Jordan of crypto
if you will
JPM do you know SPF I think it's cool
that the guy has just initials uh SPF
some on Twitter calling him the hero
right now of the industry there's
comparisons to Warren Buffett back in
the financial crisis or if you go way
back JP Morgan in the Panic of 1907
bailing out the banks before the Fed was
even created
all right so you got it if you're a bad
guy doing bad things they will treat you
like a king if you are a good guy doing
good things say Donald Trump five years
ago say Ron DeSantis today they will
treat you horribly who else is in the
midst of that right now well Elon Musk
right so if you look at Sam bankman
bankman freed he was the second largest
donor of the Democrats so you're going
to get some pretty freaking good press
coverage we just showed you some of it
now if you look at a guy like Elon Musk
well he's not a Democrat actually he was
a Democrat his whole life but just in
the last it's about eight months or so
he is now voting for Republicans has
already come out and said he would
support Ron DeSantis so what is the
Biden Administration going to do well
they're going to start looking into his
companies not because they know
anything's wrong or that he's up to no
good but they'll find something because
this is the government here's a tweet by
Jim Jordan on just that Jim Jordan of
course Republican Congressman uh surely
it's just a coincidence that the Biden
Administration is investigating one of
Elon musk's companies at the same time
musk is releasing the truth on the
hunter Biden Twitter file so they're
looking into neuralink right now which
is one of musk's companies and you
remember because we played you the video
about a week or so ago Joe Biden
literally said
at the White House we don't know that
he's doing anything wrong but we should
look that is Kabuki theater that is
Banana Republic level stuff that is not
Western democracy that is not in the
American Spirit like oh there's somebody
doing something we don't happen to
really like what he's doing so we will
figure out a way to take him out whether
whether there is one a legitimate way or
not that's what our government is doing
right now uh but every now and again
someone in the government gets asked a
good question I would say Fox News is
Peter Ducey is basically the the rare
the rarest of the rare at the moment
here he is at the White House asking
black lesbian press secretary Karin
Jean-Pierre when the White House will
delete their Twitter because obviously
it's run by this crazy white supremacist
mean capitalist dude who's into
Republicans or something and he's
releasing information we can't have that
so why is the White House on this thing
another subject
when are you guys going to delete the
White House Twitter account
why would we do that well you're saying
that you're keeping an eye on Twitter
because it might not be a suitable
platform so why use it look I want to be
very clear here the president has always
said and he has been very very clear in
his belief that it is important of
social media platforms to continue to
take steps to reduce hate speech and
misinformation and he'll we'll continue
to say that
Joe Biden all right all right I was
going to be the voice I was going to be
a little mean to Joe Biden I'm going to
try to be a little nicer than I was
about to be
um Joe or guys pulling Joe strings
nobody gives an F uh what you think
about hate speech there's no such thing
as hate speech we have the Supreme Court
which has decided that you are allowed
to say mean things about people the
government has no right to tell a tech
company or a shoe store or a barber what
is allowed to be said in their stores
okay you guys have violated the first
amendment that is obvious and you're
back on your heels but nobody cares it
doesn't matter Karin Jean-Pierre that
Joe Biden has made it clear that big
Tech should do this no it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter you are yelling in a
void it does not matter now I get it
there are bad people out there and Bad
actors out there and you can place
people at Twitter like Jim Baker who can
do bad things but in the way that our
system works or is or at least purports
to work or I believe has some pieces of
it that still were work it does not
matter about hate speech people say mean
things to me on Twitter they did just
the past this weekend people did say
mean things to me I interviewed baby
Netanyahu from Israel we're going to get
to that in a second you know if you say
anything about Israel these
whack-a-doodle all Anonymous crazy
people come out and say horrible things
they do I did not call for anyone to be
banned I blocked a couple people that's
how it is anyway what this is all
about really is that they're losing the
narrative so of course what are they
going to say about the hunter Biden
story well it's not even a real story
that's what they're going to try to say
now even though we all know something is
rotten in the state of Denmark
you had said I think six or so days ago
that the White House was watching
um closely the situation at Twitter
after Elon musk's ownership of it with
respect to misinformation and because
these files were released
um on the basis of you know
hack materials Clause at Twitter
decisions were made to censor reporting
leading up to the election my question
was is it the White House view that
these decisions were made appropriately
in light of what has come out which
Decisions by whom by Twitter by Twitter
on okay so look
we see this as a an interesting or a
coincidence if I may that uh that he
would so haphazardly uh Twitter was so
haphazardly pushed this distraction uh
that is a that is a full of old news if
you think
he's horrible she makes Jen Saki
look like Margaret Thatcher she really
does uh this is old news this is a
distraction
um the world's richest man buying the
tech company to now show the world that
the government was coordinating to
silence dissent on at least the hunter
Biden laptop story and as I said earlier
I think we're going to find out a whole
bunch more like way more when it comes
to covid and why Dr Robert Malone and
Peter McCullough were banned from
Twitter why people who said that this
might be coming from a lab leak in China
we're banned from Twitter etc etc uh
it's a distraction it's about timing
everything they say is a lie everything
they say is an absolute lie and why do
they lie about everything it's either
one of two things the most generous
version
because they're not very good at their
jobs they're just not very good these
people are inept in buffoons and they're
all hired because of diversity or
they're just generally incompetent
something like that and I would say the
more cynical version which is probably
closer to the truth is that the modern
democratic party as it exists with its
collusion with big Tech and its
collusion with big corporate press is
actually trying to destroy the United
States of America I don't think that
that's like a great jump these people
don't like our founding they don't like
our institutions if the Supreme Court
makes a decision they don't like they
want to pack the court they believe that
you can do all of your uh all of your
legislative action through the executive
branch that the government should the
President should just be able to sign
something to make it happen they don't
like this place so maybe it is within
them to do all of the things that you
wouldn't really want done if you did
like this place one of those things that
you might want to do if you like this
place is you'd secure the Border you'd
say boy we got it pretty good here sort
of like at my house I have a fence that
surrounds the whole house I don't just
let anyone into my property that's my
policy I let you guys in today and I
have coveted so while
um
but we have not secured our border and
when a certain orange man tried to
secure our border they said that he was
racist and all of those things but now
we know that we're having more border
crossings this year than in ever any
other year in modern history uh and
Peter Ducey who I mentioned before well
he asked Joe Biden about that and just
the answer it's just it's just so
perfect
because they're more important than
going on they're going to invest
billions of dollars in a new Enterprise
all right so I don't know what he means
about they're going to invest billions
of dollars in a new Enterprise but there
are more important things going on than
the Border now at some level that might
be true if Joe Biden was really sitting
down every day and dealing with the
economy stuff and that way he was like I
just have to deal with the economy stuff
and that's it but we know he's not and
what do you mean what what really is
more important a country is not a
country if it does not have a border if
you cannot say these people are our
citizens thus deserve the protections
guaranteed by our state and these people
are not and we can figure out how to let
some more people in perhaps and we can
figure out what to do with the people
who are already here but that they
refuse to even go down there and they're
so dismissive of it is absolutely
incredible but let's contrast that and
here's you know how we end the show we
try to end the show on a positive note
let's contrast Joe Biden's leadership
with what's going down here in Florida
right now this is absolutely incredible
so you know that about six weeks ago we
had what Ron DeSantis described as a
Biblical storm everyone basically said
this was the once in a hundred year
storm in essence a category five
hurricane hits Southwest Florida and
just stopped
it basically just stopped on Sanibel and
Captiva into into Fort Myers Beach it
just stopped and wrecked incredible
Carnage on Southwest Florida uh well
we've got a tweet here this is over the
weekend from Florida's voice as to
what's going on just in Governor Ron
DeSantis says Biden administration's
FEMA denied emergency funds request says
state will provide 25 million for
supplies to repair damaged homes
affected by Hurricane Ian yeah you got
that right guys we've given something
like at least 10 billion to Ukraine can
I get a number on that is there even a
number you got a Ukraine calculator
thing
um we have given billions and billions
of dollars to Ukraine we have no
receipts remember I had Rand Paul on
he's just trying to get receipts hey
guys are we buying coffee with this
money or what are we doing with the cash
guys but we can find billions of dollars
but FEMA has cut
cut their help here in the state of art
20.3 billion thank you 20.3 billion
that's the number that we've given
Ukraine we're FEMA is cutting dollars to
Florida these are the leaders of the
United States right now uh however here
in Florida we have America's governor
and he ain't taking [ __ ] from this
Administration uh here he is uh saying
what Florida is going to do to pick up
the slack we're not just going to sit
there
um and and and take no for an answer and
so we're going to figure out what we can
do so that's what we're doing today we
want to cut through bureaucracy we want
to bring relief to impacted Floridians
regardless of whether FEMA wants to be a
part of that so today I'm announcing
Florida will be providing up to 25
million dollars through State funds to
purchase building materials and provide
those materials to verified non-profit
organizations to restore damaged homes
to livable conditions so that Floridians
can move back into their own home you
know the governor actually sounds a
little under the weather himself but
it's not stopping him he is out there
every single day giving press
conferences talking to the press and
doing the right thing you know Florida
has an incredible Surplus an incredible
budget surplus despite having no state
income tax and he's saying hey the feds
it's just obvious guys like you know it
if this hit California if this hit New
York the FED is all in the FED at Joe
Biden Administration does not like Ron
DeSantis they want Florida to be
punished you may remember my interview
from about a month ago with Dennis
Prager where we talked about this during
it was right in the aftermath of the
hurricane and Dennis said that he does
not give him any great pleasure to say
it but he believes that the government
would gladly harm the people of Florida
if that helped them politically so FEMA
what is their job
what is their job it is to help these
disaster areas but in Florida they don't
want to do it so DeSantis is going in
and using the state's money and guess
what this is why he won by 20 points
it's why he'll continue to win and we'll
see what the future holds for him but he
went on to explain what his role as a
leader is and and uh by golly I think we
need a little of that you don't win by
1.5 million votes unless you're doing an
agenda that a lot of people buy into
that's just the honest truth
and so what I do
what I do is uh I let my actions speak
you know I'm not always out there
commentating on social media doing this
doing that I know there's some that
think that that's this I'm in the media
think you have to be constantly glued to
your computer all day that's not how I
live my life it's not leadership
leadership is about setting the vision
and then producing results and so our
actions are really what matters and I
think if you look at our actions our
actions have been very strong they've
been very thorough and we've delivered
historic results for the people of this
state and you know what we've only just
begun thanks everybody
competency Clarity I'm not going to be
distracted I'm going to do what you guys
voted for me to do uh and by the way I
just got reelected by a landslide and
this is just the beginning ain't it
refreshing ain't it refreshing and and
really screw the the people at FEMA and
the administration who decided on this
decision we just don't need your help
here but uh that you that you put
politics above these people's lives it's
disgusting but we don't expect much more
from you but I want to continue on that
thread of good leadership because you
know the other thing that's happening
right now uh is that there is a battle
for the RNC chair this is the Republican
Council chair which has been run by
Ronald McDonald uh sorry is it Ronald
McDaniel
uh Rhonda McDaniel uh and a lot of
people don't like her they feel like
she's just not look we can look at the
results of the midterms you know the
wave did not happen Republicans got
Congress which is Big it's important
Biden will be stymied a lot for the next
two years but clearly there there is
this internal fight of whether Trump is
going to lead this thing or not anyway
harmeet Dylan harmeet who I've had on
the show several times before she's a
friend she is a phenomenal first
amendment lawyer she works with Ron
Coleman who we had on the uh the round
table about two weeks ago uh she has
been winning lawsuits against Google
related to free speech she has defended
I think she was the lawyer for the Nick
Sandman case like she's she's just an
absolute All-Star
she announced just two or three days ago
that she is running for RNC chair she
actually did it live on Tucker Carlson
again didn't do as well in the midterms
as expected and so it's fair to ask well
whose fault is that uh and a lot of
people are asking that you may have seen
reports on a potential challenge to the
current leadership of the Republican
National Committee and those reports
suggest that our friend frequent guests
in the show her meet Dylan is
considering a run against Ronda Romney
McDaniel as chair of the RNC is that
true well no one would know better than
hermit Dylan herself chairman of the
Republican National Lawyers Association
who joins us now I mean thanks so much
for coming on is it true that you plan
to run for RNC chair
well Tucker I'm going to announce
tonight that actually I am going to run
for RNC chair and the reason is that you
know to play off of a famous catchphrase
Republicans are tired of losing and I
think that we really need to radically
reshape our leadership in order to win
and we can't keep running elections like
we did in the 90s and the 2000s and we
really have to modernize to compete with
the Democrats dollar for dollar and the
ways they fundraise the way they deliver
their ballots to the ballot boxes our
messaging needs to be fresh and positive
and not just reactive to news cycles and
what the Democrats are doing
good people getting involved our meat is
a good person and she has a track record
of fighting that goes to that track
record that Ron DeSantis is talking
about you pick the fights you you win
the fights and then people will back you
for it she is a long shot because the
way the RNC works just like the DNC I
mean it's just this endless swamp
related machine so it's a very long shot
for her to actually get control of the
RNC but I think she has the right ideas
that we have to match them dollar for a
dollar we have to figure out how to
ballot Harvest if that's what they're
going to do even if we don't want to do
it all of those things uh but really the
reason I wanted to show you that is that
there's always hope when good people get
involved when people stand up when
people have an idea and they don't just
let that idea sit in their brain but
they start talking about it with other
people and then they start acting on
that you can do incredible things you
can you can save a state from going off
the abyss you can ensure your family's
future and in the case of uh what I
talked about with BB Netanyahu uh you
can actually restore a people to their
rightful Homeland this is a little
snippet of my interview with Israeli
twice as I described him in the intro
twice and future Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu it's also millions
and millions of people not only millions
of uh of uh people in Israel millions of
Jews throughout the world but millions
of not millions of non-jews who see in
the story of Israel
um
a parable for Humanity because if the
Jewish people can overcome the most
Dreadful odds in history you can come
back from the dead can
afford uh this river between
Annihilation and salvation
and build this remarkable state
then there's hope for all of humanity
what do I say you gotta have hope right
it's like that's right that's right and
as screwy as things seem now things can
be a hell of a lot screwier right when
he talks about that River uh what was it
Redemption and salvation it's like
amazing things can happen and things
have been way worse than they are right
now and we just need more brave people
to stand up and and fight for what's
right that's what I hope you will
continue to do uh part two of my
interview with BB will be up today is
that right part two yes we'll be up
today the full thing is up at
reubenreport.locals.com uh ad free uh as
always couple comments from the locals
community and then we got a cold close
for you Amy Says quick guys get out your
masks you know you can get covet over
the computer those Zoom meetings uh
folks in 2020 showed us the way right
when those idiots on Zoom alone in their
houses were wearing masks
I just want to say we have a great
health care plan and as you guys know I
pay for all full health care so you guys
are good to go no matter what happens
here and if you and you know what you
know what guys chicken soup on me today
I'm not kidding you guys ordered some
chicken soup you expensive that's what
we're gonna do uh Kathy says Elon Musk
is going to be the one to drain the
swamp look if he can't do it nobody can
and maybe nobody can and maybe the thing
will always exist and maybe every now
and again we'll get little wins and it
just but but overall you sort of just
slide in a certain way maybe it's
something like that
um but that's why I wanted to play the
Netanyahu clip at the end because as he
said a people could basically come back
from the dead right after the ashes of
the Holocaust and reconstitute their
National Homeland it's like anything's
possible if you have an idea
and a will to live and and truth and
Justice on your side like you can make
good things happen we're doing it right
here in Florida it doesn't mean we're
doing it all over the country but people
will make their decisions as to where
they want to leave and everything else
so there you go uh EK says do you think
not caring what people say makes you
uncancelable uncancelable I think that's
a big part of it you know it's it's kind
of funny because when you when you're
growing up what they always tell kids
well I don't care what anyone thinks
about you and it's a little dismissive
to say that I can now especially as a as
a parent of two babies like I think
about now what am I going to say to them
as they get older and pressures come
with this and that or friends say mean
things to them or whatever whatever it
might be you know
um and it's like you can't just say to
them well don't care what anyone thinks
it's not it's not that easy like that's
kind of right to some degree but it's
more right it's more like if you really
know what you think and why you think it
well then you shouldn't care you know
and then because then when someone says
something crazy to you you won't go nuts
you it won't Crush you to your core one
of the reasons that the left is so
triggered and outraged these days and
everything is an affront to their truth
is because they don't know why they
believe what they believe they just know
they believe it and that is not enough
so I think not caring is a huge portion
but I can't sit here as a 46 year old
adult that's got a decent thing going on
on this earth like I can't tell you that
I simply don't care what people say
about me right like sometimes people
write nice things about me and I'm like
boy that that's nice and sometimes they
say mean things and I well I wish they
didn't do that but I think it's a big
component letting a lot of it go you're
in control of your mind and your
emotions and all that stuff and if you
can if you can own that
man that's your force field and then
yeah sure every year it's not going to
be endlessly impenetrable but then you
know if you picture yourself and picture
a force field around you and you're
under attack all the time and maybe a
real freaking nuke bomb is gonna hit it
and some stuff's gonna get through and
you'll but you'll be able to deal with
it but most of the BS that's going to
come your way
is going to hit that force field and it
won't hit you uh guys if you have not
subscribed please do on rumble.com
reubenreport
reubenreport.locals.com uh part one of
my interview with BB Netanyahu is up
right now part two will be up later
today and as I said earlier uh the full
thing is up ad free
reubenreport.locals.com
I have to say guys 55 minutes into this
show covid I don't think I had any major
screw-ups I don't think I choked on my
own phlegm and uh how much more could
you ask for a program of this nature
pretty good pretty good uh guys we leave
you I think this is a fitting way to
leave you uh Dennis Prager on Courage
courage is the rarest of the good traits
in human beings and it is the one upon
which all the others are dependent
because without courage
kindness and integrity and all these
other wonderful things
don't don't amount to much because the
world demands courage on on every plane
in life